thank you
all right
sometimes it takes a couple of seconds
for their live stream to pick up but
I believe that we should be live now
yes and hello everyone welcome to this
live event my name is Maria and I'll be
your host today so go ahead and say hi
in the YouTube chat
um as with
um
so this event is to celebrate the launch
of our brand new course on audio
Transformers and as most things
hagenface does the course is open source
free and created by a team that has
expertise in the domain and a drive to
share knowledge and democratize machine
learning I am proud to be part of the
team that has brought to you the uh this
new course and we're also joined by two
other team members so we've got sanchi
say hello
um sanchit is a machine learning
research engineer on at hug and face and
we have VB
who is machine learning developer
Advocate engineer so if you have any
questions about the course drop them in
the chat we are going to try to stay on
top of them keep up with your questions
and
today we have officially launched the
course so the first couple of units are
already available and they teach about
the specifics of audio data common audio
tasks and over the next few weeks we
will be releasing more units and you'll
learn about Transformer architectures
which are commonly used for audio tasks
and nuances of selecting appropriate
data pre-trained models fine-tuning your
own models for classification for speech
recognition text to speech and much more
so today we have invited some amazing
guests to help us celebrate the launch
of this course and our guests will share
their insights experiences nuggets of
wisdom
to hopefully Inspire and motivate you to
learn and build your own things and so
let me quickly introduce our speakers
we have uh
silkwan Kim
say hello
who is a principal applied scientist at
Amazon Alexa AI let me bring up my notes
so I don't mix anything up so prior to
joining Amazon in 2019
soak one conductive work in natural
language understanding and spoken
dialogue systems where he was an NLP
research scientist at Adobe research and
a research scientist at The Institute of
infocom research in Singapore so Juan
completed his PhD work at pohan
University of Science and Technology in
Korea and he has authored numerous
peer-reviewed papers in international
journals and conferences his recent
research has centered around knowledge
grounded conversational modeling
and soquan actively contributes to
multiple research communities we are
thrilled to welcome you and we are
looking forward to your talk which is
going to be first today
next I'm happy to introduce Brian McPhee
who is an assistant professor of Music
technology and data science at New York
University he received his Bachelor of
Science degree in computer science from
the University of California Santa Cruz
and Masters and PhD degrees in computer
science and engineering from the
University of California
his work sorry University of California
San Diego
um his work lies at the intersection of
machine learning and audio analysis he
is an active open source software
developer and the principal maintainer
of the librosa package for audio
analysis
and when you started working through the
course in the first unit you will get
your hands on using this package so
um Brian's talk is going to be very
helpful for you to get to know the
package a little bit better
um so these are the introductions thank
you everybody for joining us we are
happy to see you we are happy to be able
to
share the presentations from our invited
guests
and
feel free to go ahead and drop your
questions to us or to the speakers in
the YouTube chat
um we want this to be a bit more
interactive so you there will be
presentations but after the
presentations we have reserved some time
for questions for
uh discussions for opinions and so
everybody Welcome to post their
questions in the YouTube chat if you are
on Discord you can also start
discussions there
and
yes with that
um
I'm happy to
give the stage over to Silicon
and let me just
um
bring the slides
and make sure that everything is ready
for a first presentation so give a warm
welcome say hello
and we're ready to start I'm just going
to remove everybody else from the screen
so that the stage is all yours
yeah thanks Maria for the great
introduction and uh yeah thanks for
having me and first of all uh
congratulations for launching a new
audio Transformers course and uh I'm so
con Kim uh from Amazon Alexa and today
I'm going to present our previous work
and actually this is a kind of the use
case of Transformers our library uh to
process uh the audio files basically the
speech files and the title of this talk
is how robust argue and evaluating task
oriented dialogue systems on spoken
conversation and as you can see from
this title uh so I'm a basically a
dialogue researcher and my background is
mostly for the NLP not for the speech
but we needed to uh address some speech
related problems in the dialogue systems
so yeah this work was uh a joint work
with my team members young the Alex
Karthik Bennett lag
and uh
yeah so the
um motivation of this work was that so
you know uh there have been many uh the
public data sets are becoming available
for dialogue research and dialogue
system development but the thing is that
um most of the data set were written
conversations because the main uh the
way of collecting the dialogue data is
uh through the cloud searching and
usually we launch this kind of uh web
page uh to collect the text uh the
responses or text uh the written text
conversations from the cloud workers and
recently uh with the advancement of the
larger language models uh some many
people try to generate or augment uh
this kind of dialogue data uh using The
Ledger the generative larger language
models but here uh the result from the
larger language models also the written
conversations so yeah that was the uh
background uh that we had uh for this
work and uh yeah here is one uh example
of written conversation and as you could
see here uh so all the uh utterances all
the text
uh from the speakers are uh clearly
written so grammatically perfect and so
it looks okay but uh when we consider
some practical applications of spoken
dialogue systems so you know there
should be some uh gaps between the
written text and the spoken languages
the first of all uh you know there is
some differences in the way of writing
and way of speaking and uh in the spoken
conversations in uh from for example
from our daily conversation uh we use so
many distillances uh like this the high
I'm looking for a place at oral or
something like that so that is is not uh
that happening in the written uh
conversations that we collect from the
cloud sourcing or larger language models
so yeah
yeah uh so one uh the major differences
between written data and spoken data and
uh another thing uh is that so to build
a system to
uh handle the spoken input from the
users so we need to use the automatic
speech recognition uh and sometimes the
automatic speech recognition produce
some noisy recognition rejects like this
the the pre the actual run is price
range but that could be misrecognized as
a pressure engine and the parking cost
could be also misrecognized as a
different word uh with uh the different
meaning so yeah this kind of uh the ASR
errors so that is another issue in uh
handling the addressing the spoken
inputs in uh developing the spoken
dialogue systems
so uh to address uh the challenges in uh
such a spoken conversations
uh we uh
try to set up a new Benchmark task uh
and this Benchmark tasks are included to
uh main tasks uh the first one is uh
dialogue State tracking which is a
traditional uh problem in dialogue
research and the other thing is uh the
knowledge grounded response Generations
which is a relatively new task but that
has been recently widely studied in the
diet research field uh the first uh
dialogue State tracking task is like
this uh so I think the animation is not
working so but anyway so like here uh
you can see that at the end of this
conversation uh the users score uh is to
find the hotel in Fisherman's World in
San Francisco uh and uh the user uh
changed the preference the for the price
range from the uh
I think uh from moderate to the
expensive I think uh yeah the the
originally the user asked the moderate
price range but uh changed the price
rate the change in their mind uh from
moderate to the expansive so the goal of
dialogue State tracking is to capture
this kind of changes and this kind of uh
the users the preference or user score
at each moment so uh once this style of
state is uh predicted uh in uh the
structured representation like this uh
by the dialogue site tracking model so
it this information is used to find the
relevant information from the domain API
or database in this case the domain API
is the hotel a search API or something
to generate the uh the next response by
the system and uh continue the
conversations uh to achieve the final
goal so yeah that is the uh an example
of uh the multi-domain dialogue State
tracking problem uh that is the first
task that we had in our benchmark
and uh the second uh task is knowledge
grounded dialogue modeling uh for this
one
uh so this was uh
the introduced by our team and we
organized a the previous track uh in
2020 on the the ninth uh dialogue system
technology challenge track and for this
one uh we uh defined three sub-tasks the
first one is energy second detection uh
followed by energy selection and
knowledge grounded generation
and uh this is an example the motivation
here is that uh so
in the previous dialogue State tracking
task we assumed that all the dialogue
State can be represented uh as a
predefined uh dialogue state
representation and uh the information is
available the relevant information to
the dialogue state is available from the
database so the API but uh in practice
there could be some requests from the
customer the from the user which is out
of the scope from the API or out of the
scope from our dialogue state
representation
so in this case but we know that usually
this kind of information is available
somewhere in the web uh for example the
hotel website or hotel booking uh the
website so we can find some information
in uh multiple different formats like uh
for example for the FAQs uh some FAQs
include this kind of information like
the parking costs or something
so the goal here is to uh go up this
task is to decide whether we are we need
some external knowledge beyond the API
or database and uh so once this uh stunt
detection is uh done and a given turn is
predicted as a uh the knowledge seeking
turn which requires the external
knowledge access so we go to the
knowledge selection to actually retrieve
the relevant Knowledge from the large
candidates and then finally we generate
the responses we don't need on the
selected energy from the previous task
so that was the definition of the of the
second task
and to study this uh digital tasks on
the spoken conversations we actually
collect the spoken human dialogues about
the San Francisco contention for the
hotel restaurant and the attraction in
San Francisco
and this data was collected by pairing
two participants uh one uh person for
each session uh was playing a lore of a
user and for the user side participant
we provided a set of specific goals like
uh so what a kind of attraction or what
kind of hotels the user is looking for
and uh so some booking details as well
and uh for the other side for the Asian
side uh the agent had the access to the
domain database and all the knowledge
about hotels and restaurants and
attractions and the agent uh the uh read
read the conversation to provide the uh
the information requested by the user
and yeah this part uh is uh related to
the hooking faces Transformers library
and so as I mentioned before I'm not a
speech guy so I actually had no idea how
we can uh translate or transcribe uh the
human human uh the conversation
recordings uh into the ASM result but at
that time uh the hugging phase
Transformers uh the release the waved
back 2.0 support this is a pre-trained
uh model to get the representation from
the uh the speech audio files into the
vector representation and uh the ASL
result can be decoded based on the
representation the embedding
representation and we fine-tuned uh the
way with fact 2.0 pre-trained mode there
on the 900 906 towers of Liberty speech
uh so we originally we tried this find
pre-trained model itself but there was
some uh gaps between this training data
set I went and our data set because this
delivery speech was the kind of the
audiobook so the a single person I'll
read the book and that recording was
included in this Liberties page uh but
our data set was dialogues between two
people and the content were very
different from the book content so we
fine-tuned with the 10 percent of our
recordings so all these fine-tuning and
the decoding all these things were done
uh using the Transformers library and uh
the performance wise uh it achieved
around a 266 WR so that was quite high
but so it was a kind of by purpose
because we wanted to evaluate the low
business of the dialogue models against
uh such uh High ASR noises and ASL
drivers and you can find the wave to
vect uh details using the hooking phase
from the QR code that I put on this page
and uh
yeah this is uh yeah so I see a question
about the uh uh so yeah that
uh
the question is about the way with Fagan
uh so what we used was the uh the
original version of the waved effect so
uh I
so yeah I think uh so I don't know
whether the course include any uh the
recent versions of the way to back but
this work was done about two years ago
so at the time we used the original
version of the wave effect to generate
the fine tune and generate the uh the
ASL result on our data set uh and this
is the statistics uh that uh we had and
uh so we actually used uh this yeah this
part the the bottom part the testing
part uh for the validation and test data
set so that was uh the spoken part of
our data set and uh we uh organized a
public Benchmark under the tens dialogue
system technology challenge track uh
using this data set as a validation and
test data set and the setup was like
this we used the previous written
dialogue data set as the training data
set and a part of the validation data
set where we use this uh the our spoken
data so there's a test set to see uh
uh the how the models are trained on the
written data set works for the spoken
data set that we had
uh and as for the Baseline so we took
the state of the art our dialogue State
tracking uh model so at that time uh the
3p uh so that was a joint uh model uh on
top of the board for the classification
and spam detection over there and 3p was
used for the Baseline for DST
and Nova was used for the second task
for the knowledge grounded distance
generation and that was uh actually the
winner winning uh system for our dstc 9
track for the original Benchmark on the
written data set and this is also uh
based on the plate to the pre-trained
pre-trained model and that is uh the
classification followed by the
generation motor uh so with uh the
singular model for each subtask for our
knowledge grounded at least one
generation pipeline
and yeah here's here is the Baseline
widget so uh this uh is based on the
borders uh fine-tuned on the written
text as it is and you can see that there
was huge gap between the result and the
written test data set and the spoken
data spoken test data set so as you can
see here here for the task one the
jungle accuracy uh the state of the
arduing directors at the time on the
multi was 2.1 written test data set was
over 50 percent but surprisingly uh that
the same model worked uh very worse for
our spoken test data set and the during
directors was even below one percent so
when we just used this model with no
modification
or no augmentation on that
and also for the tasks too uh the
performance degradation from the test
the written test data set to the spoken
test data set uh was quite significant
uh for the nurse selection it went down
from 88 to 49 it was huge and also for
the generation metrics so yeah that was
uh went from uh 30 weeks to uh the
driver 13. so it didn't very uh didn't
work very well on the spoken test it is
that was the observation from our
basement in widget
but uh after uh getting the result uh
from our challenge participant so yeah
we realized that uh the our challenge
the teams participated in our challenge
did a great job so you can see here uh
the this is the uh the 13th list of the
the result uh for the Task 1 participant
and uh the top uh the role is the
winning team for this task and you can
see that the jungle accuracy from this
uh the best team the best entry was 46
percent uh so and you can uh see that
the Baseline is uh the below one percent
but uh uh the highly ranked teams did a
great job and uh so looking at the prop
the method used in the top teams uh one
notable thing was that uh the yeah
conventionally the classification and
extraction was the main method for
dialogue State tracking but from this
Benchmark the generation based method
were much better than the classification
and extraction based method by uh for
the state tracking problem and this is
well aligned with the reset Trend
because right now we are using uh the
generate generative language models for
most of the tasks including this
dialogue State tracking so this is not
very surprising uh at this moment but
yeah that was the key observation at the
time and another thing is that uh all
the top four teams uh the price some
data augmentation from the written text
the written data set to more uh spoken
uh data like so and especially the top
team the a11 so this team tried three
different data augmentation methods
including various substitution this is
the entity replacement with the
alternative entity from the ontology and
dialogue generation which is to generate
a new dialog flow so in addition to the
ones in the training data set and uh
foreign
so that worked very well so this is data
augmentation was another key to success
for the top systems and the other one is
the modern example and this is very
common in this kind of public Benchmark
and they tried uh they trained uh
multiple different versions of their
motors with different configurations and
for uh the final result they just unsung
the result from the multiple motors and
that helped uh helped to boost the
performances and win the challenge
then uh yeah that was the the task one
result for the dialogue State tracking
and for the second task uh there was uh
about 60 and 370 by 16 teams in total
and this is the overall result
and uh so here it uh this uh shows the
uh the comparisons of the uh
participating teams wizard compared to
our Baseline and uh for time detection
and energy selection are majority of the
teams achieved much improved the
performances compared to our Baseline
uh and also response generation
especially for the response generation
uh the base yeah the performance
Improvement by the systems was huge from
the Baseline and that was also the same
uh from our human evaluation result and
you can see here uh the top teams uh got
uh about 3.5 or three point each uh the
ratings out of five uh from our human
evaluation result while our baselines uh
stayed about 2.7
so yeah the Gap was significant
and again uh for the
the two uh we observed uh the same uh
Trend so that the data augmentation uh
was uh one key to achieve the high
performances on uh the subtasks that we
had and also modern example hurt so yeah
these were aligned with the task from
widget
okay so uh the key takeaways from this
dstc 10 uh the task track 2 uh was that
the Baseline uh sutamu there's trained
on the written data failed to address
the spoken data that was the the first
conclusion and another thing is that
data orientation was a key uh to uh
achieve High performances on both tasks
are on the spoken data set because we
have limited amount of the training data
set uh collected from the spoken
conversation so uh the data augmentation
is important uh also in the practical
application because we need to convert
the existing data set into more uh the
closure to the uh the actual input to
the spoken direct system and for the
dial of set tracking the generation
based method was better uh to handle the
energy test Set uh compared to the
extraction or classification based
method and uh The Ensemble helped to
boost the scores and win the challenge
for both both tasks
okay and uh so this was uh this this
result was present uh uh this uh shared
and pleasant to then we wrapped up this
track uh in the beginning of 2022 so it
uh was about uh one year ago so more
than one year ago and so since then
there has been so many changes and so
many uh uh updates uh from the research
field especially with the Ledger linking
models so I think uh as one feature
Direction I think it would be
interesting to revisit this task uh and
try to see whether the latest uh the
status of the art larger language models
uh how how did these motors work also
for the spoken data set that we had so
that is uh one potential feature
Direction and the other direction is
end-to-end approaches I think so now uh
we are still using the pipeline
architecture uh to recognize this speech
to transcribe the speech to the text
first and applying the the models
trained on the written text so this kind
of pipeline architecture is not very
robust in general to handle the energy
uh the uh the largest the spoken inputs
the due to the accumulated errors uh
from the the earlier component in the
pipeline so the Anton approach by taking
the speech directly to the predict or
generate the final the downstream Tasker
output so that may be another future
Direction uh
okay uh and yeah I think that's it from
my side and you can find our data set
and our paper uh from the QR code here
and uh so one thing is that uh so we
have only released our uh the ASL result
with the no speech data set the audio
audio files are not really released yet
but there have been so many uh requests
from our Challenger participants so we
have been working on internally uh to
release this data but it takes some time
but anyway so once it is done and we are
releasing uh this audio data set so we
will announce it in dstc mailing list so
if you are interested in this data so
please so we I encourage encourage uh
you to join this mailing list and stay
tuned on the update
okay that's it and thanks for uh
listening and I I'll be happy to answer
any question
thank you so much it was a
vintage I'm going to bring back to the
screen
folks from the team
who were monitoring the questions and uh
the speakers as well
I will keep the slide on a little longer
so that people can take a picture and
join the mailing list to learn more
about the data and any other
announcement that you may be sharing
using this email list
um
does anybody want to start with a
question
VB maybe you
you're muted
sorry too many brothers
um uh thank you so much for for such a
brilliant talk
um
sorry I'm butchering your name
um uh I had a question and there were a
couple questions in the um in the chat
one of them was about the paper so thank
you so much for putting the the QR code
up there
um uh just sort of like personal
curiosity if you were to you know
replicate the study say you know today
uh and and I know that previously like
you had
um sort of used the wave to wake to
architecture and now with the with the
Advent of sort of more uh you know uh
encoder decoder architectures like
whisper
um and also with with sort of new
um other sort of multilingual uh
variants of vf2 back to as well
um what do you think like which
direction would you want to go to uh or
or would you would you want to try
specifically from like an architectural
standpoint and if you have any sort of
insights about that that could be great
yeah that's a great question yeah yeah
and definitely so it will be worse to
try the uh the latest status of the art
architectures to reproduce This research
and I think so if we release this audio
data I think that could be done by
probably I think so but uh the thing is
that at the Times our purpose was to
generate some uh
the ASL result with any existing open
source model at the time and so that is
the reason why we use the wave to back
because uh that was the state of the art
so if I remember correctly but so I
believe that so with the advancement of
the ASR representation and architecture
of nowadays so we can uh largely improve
the WR you can largely reduce the wdr so
because WL was quite high for our data
so that's okay for uh the evaluating the
dialogue the lowestness of our dialogue
models but that was not very realistic
because now we have much better ASR uh
Solutions so the in practice the WL will
be much lower than our settings so it
will be yeah definitely worth to try to
get some more improved as in digital 10
to do the evaluation again on our uh not
our the uh the dialogue models on the
improved as religion I think that will
be a definitely a worse traction I think
brilliant uh thank you so much for that
um response I'm just looking through
um the questions I think like questions
right now are like a mix of uh the
questions for the course and so on
um but at the moment I don't see any
other uh
relevant question so to speak
so I have a a question
if you don't mind um so you mentioned
different ways to augment data and since
this paper came out about a year ago
with this research came out about a year
ago have you seen in the past year any
new techniques to augment data that
could they have potential to be useful
to this particular case yeah so yeah
that's a great question and uh so in
that particularly for our data set but
you know so this kind of data
augmentation is a kind of the defect
standard right now to generate some data
and improve the uh the quantity and
quality of the data set uh with the
advancement of the larger language
models and for the dialogue research
field in uh General so many people try
to gen to create the data for instance
uh so for arpaca or vicuna so all these
uh the motors will fine-tuned uh on top
of the Llama but the training data sets
were obtained from or open AIS apis so
that was not a fine-tuned solid not
created by the cloud sourcing manually
so this was based on the uh the
automatically generated data set using
the larger LNG motor so definitely this
kind of things will be uh the new things
on top of the data augmentation method
that our challenge participants tried so
yeah that's the reason why I listed that
as a potential future direction to
revisit our task because the legend
language model can do uh probably can do
much better in both data augmentation
and the prediction and the response
generation themselves so The Ledger
language there could be uh one thing
that we can try on this uh yeah data
augmentation I think
thank you so much
um Phoebe do we have any questions from
the audience that we could ask
um not at the moment there are a lot of
like course related questions so
well if there's is no questions about
this particular talk then we can move on
to our next presenter
um
and I am happy to introduce Paige Bailey
who has joined us today uh Paige is a
lead product manager for generative
models at Google deepmind and prior to
returning to Google deepmind team page
spent just over here at Microsoft as the
Director of machine learning and mlops
at GitHub working on projects like
GitHub code spaces and cope Island I'm
sure you have heard of them
and as a former applied ml engineer in
Asia research Chevron and on NASA
project projects page can't imagine a
more exciting Charter than accelerating
developer productivity with machine
learning and unlocking the capabilities
of these models for users so we are
thrilled to have Paige join us among
other speakers and to share her
presentation
um
thank you so much thank you so much for
joining us as usual drop your comments
and questions in the chat so we can get
back to them at the end of the
presentation
and I'm going to give the floor to page
awesome
uh excellent
do you have a slides to
um I do have slides
um let's see
I
so so it's asking me to upload a file
um
and upload
okay so we're gonna give you
upload a minute to do that so don't
worry excellent thank you I apologize
and also I um I apologize as well this
is uh so file
download
um
as
PDF document
let's see that's what that should work
yep and then I am dialing in today from
the London office
um the uh I'm dialing in today from the
London office which is uh currently
where Google deepminder most of Google
deepmind sits
um so uh so if you see everything
looking particularly beautiful today uh
outside the window that is because uh
London is very beautiful today and I
should be uploading the presentation now
um I uh
it is the largest presentation so
hopefully
um yeah if I see it so I can edit just
to move
Perfection thank you
yeah have fun excellent
all right everyone I am delighted to be
here today
um as mentioned I'm the product lead for
generative models um at Google deepmind
um in particular I was responsible for
the Palm 2 launch which we'll be talking
about later in the presentation as well
as code AI which is our machine learning
is applied to software development
Charter for alphabet across both our
first party Solutions as well as our
third-party Solutions and what that
means is that we take these large
generative models
um a lot of data about the software
engineering process
um and then also I sort of apply the the
models through through various phases
um so things like code generation of
course and code explanation but also
things like automated build repairs
performance fixes security vulnerability
detection all sorts of things the reason
that I say this is because I
um I have no background whatsoever
um in generative audio I am helping with
the Gemini model which again we'll talk
about later and is multimodal
um but I do not have experience with
generative model building myself so I've
been learning a lot in the previous
presentation and I'm excited about the
questions that you all might ask
cool
um so despite me not having any
background in generative audio Google
has immense background in generative
audio and what you see here is a
presentation from Google I O which
happened pretty recently
um where we had Dan Deacon brought out
on stage and using musical M to generate
uh the pre the pre-alphabet Google I O
show so he uh and this uh gentleman
dressed in a duck suit were able to do
really really interesting things with
kind of dynamically changing the tone
and the the contents of the music
um and uh awesomely we were able to
release it externally as music LM so if
you go to this link
um I I am
happy to put the link in the chat at the
end of the presentation if folks aren't
able to to type it all out but you're
able to play around with music LM and
generate your own tracks here you can
see something called
um modern pop country ballad that you'd
hear on the top 40 radio
um and then I I also things like ambient
sounds I would listen to by the ocean or
something similar um so experiment with
it share what you've learned
um it's it's pretty cool to be able to
play with these models in real time
so uh as Google
um you know our mission is to organize
the world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful we've
been doing this for a very very long
time
um and organizing all of that
information makes for a really great
pre-training data for these large
generative models and as a result
they've driven uh you know in pursuit of
this Mission we've driven a lot of
groundbreaking work on foundational
models so both large-scale neural
networks as well as sequence to sequence
learning of course the attention is all
you need paper but also things like
instruction tuning and rhf I think the
first paper or the first blog post
really that I saw about arly Jeff was
one of the deepmind Publications in 2017
so we've been thinking about the
foundational like nuts and bolts of what
make generative models for a really
really long time and now it's become
kind of mission critical in quarter our
business
we also have great infrastructure and
tools like tpus and Jacks which is an
open source machine learning framework
in order to make such models and to make
them scale across giant clusters of
machines
um uh including like giant clusters
across data centers right like being
able to stitch all of these uh all of
these computers together and make them
you know run a single program is is a
really exciting thing to get to be a
part of
um and then of course we also have
um uh deep learning techniques
um so things like chinchilla
um you might have heard of compute
optimal models or chinchilla optimal
models Flamingo so visual visual
language models for a few shot learning
and then also fun fine-tuning these are
all kinds of things that were pioneered
at alphabet and are all critical
components for generative models
so at i o
reintroduced our latest generative model
which is building on all of these things
that we've learned in the past Palm two
and palm 2 is kind of the next iteration
of our first Palm model but it included
massive breakthroughs and multilingual
reasoning and coding capabilities
it was built on uh it was built using
Jacks and it's faster and more efficient
due to like a broad variety of model
sizes that were deployed across many
product surfaces and at i o we announced
it was deployed over in over 25 Google
products since then it's been more like
an over 38 features and products and
honestly like that is one of the coolest
things that I have ever been part of in
my career as the lead PM for Palm 2 I
was able to get it deployed into
workspaces so sheet stocks Etc as well
as Bard Magi which is our new search
experience
and then also some of the ml operations
into developer tools across collab
Android Studio as well as some of our
duet capabilities for for Google cloud
and if you're curious about it we put a
technical paper as well as some examples
and content at g dot code palm2
um I I will also add a link to that at
the end of the presentation
and so just as a few kind of tactical
examples it has improved multilingual
understanding so being able to translate
from one language to another as well as
to explain nuanced meaning in languages
um so so being able to understand why
some translations might be
miscategorized or why some translations
or jokes are funny in one language and
not others
um so so this is uh this is really
really cool and it's it's kind of a step
change in terms of model capabilities
compared to what we've seen before it
also has reasoning capabilities so being
able to understand placement for
um placement for objects that a person
might describe through text or natural
language
um and enhanced code capabilities and
one of the coolest things is that you
can also kind of mix and match these
capabilities
um as you will so here you can see an
example of a line by line descriptions
for a chunk of source code that you
generate in Korean you can also explain
in a kind of long tail languages
um so a colleague had it explains C plus
plus like a Transformer but in Malayalam
code comments so it was it's really
really nice to understand
um you know just personally how much
this might be able to open up access to
people who might not have English as a
first language but who are you know
learning how to code or learning about
math or physics Concepts
so that's really energizing
and as I mentioned it's now powering
over 38 products and features across all
of alphabet Bard is powered by Palm 2
soon to be powered by Gemini and then
the coding capabilities we had already
mentioned before
um it looks like some of the the gifts
that I might have had broke whenever I
exported as a PDF so you'll just have to
trust me and play with Bard yourself but
we've also introduced recently new
export actions for things like Gmail
docs sheets and then also replet and
cool app
um so if you generate some python code
you can export it as a collab notebook
which is pretty cool
um Bart is available in English and over
180 countries around the world it's also
available in Korean Japanese and a host
of other languages I think we've opened
up to most of those 40 languages so far
but I encourage you to to test it out to
see what you think and to share your
feedback
uh we're also this was also a gif though
I kind of like the still with like the
the dog with his tongue sticking out
um but we're we've also introduced image
understanding and also image exporting
capabilities for Bard
um so if you if you would like to
generate image content you know perhaps
you want to understand you're visiting
Chicago and you want to understand the
architecture of the city if you ask that
query it's highly likely that you will
receive images as part of the output to
show you things that you might want to
visit
um so that's that's quite cool and then
also app integration
and pretty soon also announced at i o we
will be uh uh you know we are currently
in the process of training our Gemini
model it is the first model that we're
training jointly
um as both former brain and uh and
deepmind
um and it's intended to be our most
powerful yet so you can think of it as a
super set of palm 2 capabilities
um including multimodal features and
what that means is that the model can
understand many different modalities so
not just text not just code but also
music or other kinds of audio video
images
um uh you know like CAD models all sorts
of really cool things and as a result I
think that we're going to see more and
more multimodal scenarios that models
enable over time like being able to
being able to take in a figma design and
generate the code that would be used to
create a functioning web app or being
able to describe a natural language the
kind of figma design that you would like
to see and having the UI generated for
you on the Fly I think these are really
really cool applications and we've only
just started tapping into the potential
of this so so so be on the lookout for
for more capabilities and then demo time
uh so so again uh since I just have
slides
um I have kind of the what it would look
like if I was demoing things
um and so for Bard you can ask it to do
things like creating a linear regression
and uh a linear regression model in
Python using scikit-learn and including
a funny pun
um so here it says I guess you could say
that linear regression is a pretty
straightforward model I agree
um and then you can also investigate
other drafts that you might include uh
so that
um you know model outputs are not
deterministic so you can see like
different flavors of output responses
that that might have been generated
and then also kind of these export
capabilities
uh and then you can export the the
python code to collab
um and run it
um so so being able to to kind of see
um see these things in real life is very
very cool
and we've also Incorporated machine
learning features into collab though I
think those are still yet to be released
fully externally so you can play with
the same models that are used to support
Bard directly within your collab
notebook for code Generation
Um for error explanation for automated
error fixing all sorts of things
um so uh yes powered by bard
excellent and then with that I would
like to say thank you to everyone
um thank you for having me I hope uh I
hope this was useful or meaningful or
interesting I think music and audio
generation is one of the coolest use
cases for generative models by far
um as as a person who used to spend way
too much time lurking as a DJ in her
College radio station
um so I am excited to see what you build
um and please feel free to ask away
thank you so much I'm gonna get
everybody back to the Stream
right are we all here yes we are
um
I have a question to kick things off
actually so
um given your vast experience with
applied machine learning so you you work
at Microsoft Google GitHub Google Deep
Mind and so for a lot of years and
during those years a lot of things from
the perspective of Technology have
changed so we've got a model
architectures hardware for training you
know more data and all kinds of things
but I wonder if you find
um if you can name something that is
consistent and rather what skills would
you say people should invest into that
are going to carry them through all the
turbulence of new tech and new
approaches new uh capabilities what is
the constant thing that's going to help
people
in the long term
that's a great great question and I
think I started doing machine learning
in 2009 when the world looked very
different so um so like I think the the
majority of the models that we were
working with were really things like
linear regression support Vector
machines like uh you know decision trees
you know those were those were the thing
that everybody was interested in
um and and I have to say like it's it's
right now we're living in such a state
that I've waited my entire career to see
it like this this
um you know it finally feels like we're
we're truly on the path to integrating
AI into everything that we do and and
really making it real
um for everyone out into the world some
things that have stayed consistent are
that you still have to care about data
quality
um there's this there's this kind of
myth that for training these large
generative models you can just throw
whatever you want in the pre-training
data mixtures
um and uh you know there's there's so
much data that uh the it it you know the
model kind of discerns signal somehow
even with all of the noise
um but for instruction tuning for domain
specific fine-tuning so like if you're
doing continued pre-training on source
code those sorts of things data quality
matters immensely
um and I think that's part of why if you
look at um kind of the end the data set
that was really least with anthropics
helpful harmless assistant paper
that data is just so so impactful for
building building great chat Bots
building wonderful experiences so you
always always have to care about the
data and then in terms of
um in terms of you know just like being
a solid human
um like being able to ask good questions
being able to collaborate effectively
and also being able to communicate what
you do is Mission critical important
like the algorithms the techniques the
libraries the Frameworks they're all
going to change they're going to change
constantly like they haven't stopped
changing for for a while and I don't
think they're ever going to stop
changing
um but the importance of high quality
data sets and the ability to to kind of
work with people understand where the
gaps are and collaborate effectively and
communicate what you've just done
um are all kind of they're they're never
going to cease to be important
absolutely agree with you
um VB do we have questions with in from
the audience
so there are a bunch of questions about
um how can people access Palm to when
gemina like models
um and and would there be like a public
access or would they be open source
um uh if they're open source then we'd
definitely be more more than uh
interested
awesome so right now um Palm 2 has been
released across a lot of different
product surfaces so you know I think I
mentioned if you go to Bard you can try
it out as the underlying model powering
the chat experience
um if you'd like to try it out in API
form we have made it available via
vertex AI
um so all you have to do is look for the
Palm API there's also a developer API
um if you do if you don't feel like
paying
um that that is free of charge however
all of the inputs and outputs are kind
of used for for additional you know uh
for understanding purposes and model
improvements
um so I would not recommend using the
developer API with any data that you
hold close to your heart and don't want
anybody to to use for purposes that are
not your purpose but the vertex AI apis
are the vertex AI apis you can remain
like secure in the knowledge that your
data remains your data and that any
inputs and outputs will not be used to
improve the model over time
um but those are those are the best ways
to try it out both integrated directly
Within products as well as the apis that
we've made available
brilliant there was um another question
about uh multilingual data sets for um
instruction tuning so I'm just going to
rephrase it
um uh what's what's been your experience
sort of dealing with
um instruction tuning specially for like
these really large language models
um such as palm 2 and so on and uh more
specific to like how how to get like a
better performance for say multilingual
um side of things absolutely so this is
a wonderful wonderful question
um instruction tuning is a really
challenging thing to do well and I think
it's I think it's an art like if you can
figure out how to do it it's one of the
things that can move the needle the most
for performance for your model
um there will be instances so so say you
train a generative model you can do
generic instruction tuning however that
model will not probably uh like if you
do instruction tuning just in English
language
then the model will probably forget what
it learned about all of the other
languages like it'll still be able to
generate you know Korean or Spanish or
something
um but it won't be quite as good
um so as you're as you're building out
instruction tuning sets
um if you have a model that supports
multilingual capabilities definitely
investigate multilingual instruction
tuning and then also if you are dealing
with a model that is um you know say say
you're trying to build a chat bot about
code stuff
um you should also probably do code
instruction tuning so your instruction
tuning set should not be generic um like
a like a regular text generation model
it should include questions about code
explanations code generation Etc
um and and that's that is very very
important
um even if even if it's like a like say
you want to generate uh or you want to
create a model that's very very good at
answering questions about like Android
devices your instruction tuning reset
should probably be about Android Android
use cases
and that's you know we're all kind of
building in the plane as we fly it right
like we're all you know kind of learning
through what we experience users are
asking these models and over time you
can get kind of a distribution of these
are the kinds of questions that people
ask these are the kinds of things that
they're interested in these are probably
the distribution of things I should be
including in my instruction tuning set
but at the very beginning it's just
guesswork and then afterwards it's data
science and you should be like using all
of the great questions and feedback that
your users are supplying you with to
understand what your instruction tuning
set should be
fantastic
um I cannot find
um well there is actually one question
it would be interesting to
um uh just know your uh take on this
more from
um you know uh like like in more from
your you know product manager sort of
hat on
um and and more from like how you see
the industry which is like how do you
see these sort of generative um sort of
Music
um and also like pretty much any
generative model sort of see
um you know affecting like the larger
Industries
um in the future or like currently and
you know
um specifically for music if you've seen
any like creative use cases maybe
internally
um and so on if you uh if you want to
talk about that yeah I think one of the
things that I'm most excited about is
um I am a huge fan of indie games
and uh and indie games are usually
labors of love for everybody involved
you know you might have one person that
is attempting to like with Blood Sweat
and Tears make a make a game or even
just like a small handful of people
um and you know if even if you're a
software engineer you're a person who's
who's really gifted at being able to
create or design
um the the playing experience of the
game
um or or you know the generative
approaches for some of the characters
um you might not be the kind of person
that's great at art or great at like
music generation or you know like
composing what the what the sequences
should be
um so one of the the coolest things that
I find about models like music LM is
that you can describe like perhaps your
character is about to face a boss in
like the final level of the game and you
describe like what kind of emotions you
want the player to be experiencing as
they're like fighting this boss
character I could not compose such a
thing but I feel very grateful that if I
I built such a game there is a model
that could that could help me get to the
to the kind of in-state experience that
I would I would like to enable for my
users
um so so those are the kinds of use
cases that I get most jazzed about not
so much the like how do we create the
next like top 40 single or whatever but
how do we Empower people who are really
really gifted at like you know perhaps
60 of the things
um that would be required to produce
something and then oftentimes like the
required 40 else friction
um means that their name their game
never gets released how do we get them
over the line such that you know these
people can get their ideas and their
Creations out into the world
um
this one that's that's kind of like I
don't know if that's a good answer but
like that's that's the kind of stuff
that gets me most excited about these
ones I think that was that was brilliant
and you know like um oftentimes when we
when we look into these like music model
speed music LM be it
um you know sing song
um and so on like we we try to sort of
relate it to uh you know oh my God this
is going to be like the the next AI
singer out there and you know we're
gonna have like top 40 tracks or top 100
tracks and so on so there's also like
sort of sets context about the uh about
the fact that there are other creative
use cases for such models and it's not
really displacing anyone
um yeah and so on
um thank you so much absolutely thank
you thank you for having me I think
we're we're almost to time or or might
be a little bit over so
um yeah I think
um we should move on to our next speaker
and if everybody would like to hang out
a little longer after our last talk we
can still talk about music generation
and audio Ai and
um all the new models and architectures
and whatever else Career Development
learning
um topics that we want to cover but at
this point I think we should um say
thank you to Paige for her talk and give
the stage to Brian
I'm gonna bring your slice to the Stream
and
we got slide can you hear me
yes we can hear you
uh we can see you we can hear you we can
see your slides that's great everything
is working
and
yes so your talk is going to be on
librosa and it's a package that we also
use in the first unit of the course uh
to help learners
discover data and understand audio data
a little bit better and so happy to give
you the stage to give an introduction to
audio processing in Python
great thanks it's uh great to be here
even though I'm in my office it's great
to be here with you all uh I am going to
be talking about librosa
um it's kind of giving you the context
what it does what it's not really
intended to do and how it can fit into
your workflow but afterwards I'm totally
happy to talk about all the other topics
because there are a lot of fun things to
talk about with audio and machine
learning
so
very big picture librosa is just meant
to be tools to make it easier for you to
work with audio
primarily for a scientific context which
is what I care about
um
I've seen a few questions in the chat
during this event for the last hour
where people were kind of asking like
why is audio so much harder to work with
than say text or images hopefully in the
course of this talk you'll get a feel
for why that might be the case uh and
liberos is really meant to attack that
particular problem so it's not meant to
be a machine learning package we assume
that tensorflow or torch or scikit-learn
or whatever can handle that problem for
us what we're trying to do is give you
wrappers that make it easier to get your
data into a machine learning model take
the results out make sense of it
understand what's going on in your
content and do something useful
so that's big picture where this started
and I've been at it for about 10 years
and at this point we have over 100
contributing developers and it's fairly
mature so I'm going to give you kind of
the overview of how the package works
and uh just kind of the highlight reel
so just from the start some design
principles this is meant to be function
oriented so think numpy not class or
object oriented like SCI kit learn right
so if you're familiar with numpy
everything should feel pretty familiar
um everything is function oriented data
comes out data goes in data comes out
pretty easy to use
um one of the things that you'll find
when you work with audio data especially
if you're looking at code from different
developers or different research groups
is that there tends to be a lot of
Divergence between the ways that people
Implement things so we spent a lot of
time trying to make everything kind of
internally consistent and work well for
the average case which for me means
analysis if you're interested in
generative models our default settings
may not be the best for you but we do
try to make it easy to change things and
uh you know make it pretty clear what's
going on and how it works
the package is meant to be sort of
understandable and simple and well
documented so as much as anything else
it's meant to be a learning tool you
should be able to crack things open and
see what's going on maybe with a little
bit of work
for that reason we focus on Simplicity
and stability and kind of off-the-shelf
methods we're not looking for like the
latest and greatest model because that's
going to change every couple of weeks at
this point what we want to do is give
you tools that are easy to use and easy
to control and you can either use those
as part of your workflow or maybe as
baselines so that's kind of the scope
here
we hope that you take this stuff and use
it to make things that are better
that's the entire goal
so I'm going to give you a quick tour
um most of the stuff is taken directly
from our documentation site this link
should be easy to find for you I'll give
it again at the end but I'm going to
walk through sort of the the main
modules of package
so I've broken this down into sort of
four major parts and then within each of
those there are a few more specifics at
the top level we have what I call
general purpose tools and different
Channel purpose packages and these are
things that apply to pretty much any
kind of audio analysis
um
and this is what I'm going to spend most
of the talk covering
next level down we have things that were
I think of as music related but you see
there's a little star there and that's
because sometimes you find use cases for
these methods that are outside of Music
um so things like event onset detection
temporal segmentation those can
generalize to other types of audio
analysis so maybe like bioacoustics
problems environmental sound recognition
maybe even medical applications
sometimes use things like be tracking if
you think like heart rate monitoring
that kind of thing
these methods can be generalized a
little bit
um but these you should think of as
slightly more specific analysis methods
we have another couple of modules that
do things that specifically uh modify
either signals or representations of
signals and this you can think of as
being useful maybe for like data
augmentation uh techniques like we saw
mentioned in the first talk I use this
kind of stuff all the time to do things
like time stretching or pitch shifting
or other sorts of slicing and dicing
audio signals to make my data set a
little bit richer we have other stuff
than those specific methods but those
come up a lot
and then we have some helper functions
I'm not really going to cover these but
if you spend some time reading through
the source code you'll kind of get a
feel for what might be useful for you
so that's sort of what we have entirely
in the package I'm going to focus on
these purple modules at the top
so I'll give you a couple of code
examples and you can sort of see how
things fit together
so the main
part of the package that people run into
when they first come to using it is the
core module and anything that's in core
is going to be re-exported as
librosa.star I'll show you some code
examples in a moment uh but these are
things like
ingesting audio maybe doing stream
processing of audio synthesizing signals
maybe you want tones or chirps or clicks
or whatever for whatever reason you have
all that kind of stuff just sort of uh
ready to go
then we have what I would consider to be
low level frequency domain
Transformations
um a lot of people think yeah we have
the Fourier transform we don't need
anything else and that is definitely not
the case we have many different types of
time frequency representations and I'll
show you some examples of what that
looks like uh sometimes they're better
suited for one application sometimes
better suited for others we provide many
options for that
we have an absurd amount of code
dedicated just to handling unit
conversion which seems like a simple
basic thing but it's really easy to get
the details wrong so it's probably not
the sort of thing you should be doing
yourself but think about things like
converting between different time units
different frequency units maybe
converting Hertz to MIDI notes to music
notation either western or maybe Indian
notations we have all that stuff in
there so definitely use that if that
fits your application
and then we have a bunch of other sort
of what I would call various DSP or
Digital Signal processing functions and
these have to do with like maybe
estimating the fundamental frequency or
like the base pitch of a monophonic
signal maybe phase retrieval methods if
you're say building a generative model
to Model A spectrogram and you want to
in
estimate what the phase should be to
reconstruct the actual time domain
signal you'd use some of these methods
there's a bunch of other stuff in there
um and this goes on and on you can
export the documentation site well on
your own and you can lose lots of time
to that
let's start with I'll give you just a
little example of what sort of a hello
world for librosa would look like
um I'm not going to play this audio
sample but this is a an audio recording
it's a few seconds long and this is
something that ships with the package
[Music]
and
we have a load function and what load
does is give it a file name and there
are some other options to it in this
case I'm using using mono equals true
and what this does is if your audio file
is Stereo or multi-channel it will down
mix it to a monophonic signal so single
Channel
uh just so you have a single time domain
that represents air pressure varying
over time
by convention we're going to call that y
so think Y is the vertical axis over
time that's what our audio signal is
and it's also going to return the
sampling rate of the signal
and this tells you how many samples per
second we have so the default sampling
rate that we always remix to on load
I'll come back to this at the end of the
hawk is about 22 kilohertz and this is
fairly standard for analysis tasks
um
what this means is that every second you
have 22 000 numbers
and right away you can see this is
already very different from what you
might have in text where an entire
sentence might only be you know a few
dozen tokens here we're already in the
scale of hundreds of thousands and this
is what makes things like Transformers a
little bit unwieldy with audio so
anything you can do to make the the data
a little bit more meanable to analysis
is going to be useful
so we have our y we have our sampling
rate
usually the first kind of thing that you
might do is transform this into a
spectrogram
uh spectrogram is sort of a catch-all
term for anything that shows frequency
content changing over time
and the fundamental unit of that or the
sort of introductory version of that
that we usually see is called the short
time Fourier transform stft for short
and that is a function that just takes
time domain signal and you give it some
parameters that say how many frequencies
or how many samples you want per frame
of analysis and how many samples you
want to hop from one frame to the next
the result of this is going to be an
array called stft which I have in purple
here this is going to be a complex
valued array so the rows correspond to
the different frequencies so zero Hertz
sampling rate divided by nfft twice that
three times that up to what we call the
Nyquist frequency if you're familiar
with this idea
um The Columns represent different time
steps and the values in this array are
complex numbers which encode both the
magnitude the amount of energy at that
frequency
and a phase offset which is basically
like a delay within the frame what what
would you need to shift a sine wave
at this time step to make it line up
with what we observe in the signal
usually we throw phase out for analysis
purposes and just focus on magnitude
because that encodes a lot of the
information especially if we have
overlapping frames
so the output of this object is going to
be about half as many frequencies as the
number the nfft number here 2048 becomes
10 25. the reasons for this if you want
to know about it ask me afterwards
and the frames are now significantly
reduced right so frames corresponds to
time but we're skipping about 500
samples at every step so if we had a
signal that was about 117 000 samples
divided by 512 now we have 230 frames
now you have something that's a little
bit more tractable to a machine learning
sort of task
so this is just a very short example of
what it looks like uh to to load in a
signal and do some basic analysis but
usually we want to do a little bit more
than that
so we give you some methods that help
visualize things and these are built on
matplotlib but sort of adapted to make
things work really well for audio uh if
you've ever tried to plot a raw audio
time series the longer it gets the
harder it is to see any information
so we have a function called waveshow
that does some some nice adaptive
sampling tricks to make sure the signal
is still visible and interpretable at
different time scales that's here on the
left
and then we also have this ridiculously
overpowered function called spec show
which was originally developed for
visualizing spectrograms
but it does a lot of other things as
well and I'm not going to spend hours
going into all the details of how that
works
but the gist of it is that this gives
you sort of a good default starting
ground to understand what's going on in
your signal so had I played that signal
you would have heard a trumpet run
that's uh just doing a little
uh I think it's F Dorian sort of run
over time it would look like this
one of the things that we often do when
visualizing spectrograms is convert the
raw energies into a decibel scale and
the reason for this there are a couple
reasons one it corresponds to how humans
perceive differences in energy
uh but two more practically for our
purposes if you don't do that the whole
screen looks black and you don't really
see any content when you log scale this
to convert it to decibels you can
actually see some content in the signal
so generally I recommend doing this
whenever you're trying to understand
what's going on in your audio data
so I've thrown around a few terms uh
Without Really defining them properly so
I'm just going to take a second to do
that here so first term a sample and
this is a measurement of a continuous
signal like my voice going into this
microphone right here
we're going to measure that signal at
regularly spaced intervals
and that sequence of measurements is our
signal so this is a discrete signal a
sample index let's say we have a sample
index n corresponds to the time where n
is divided by the sampling rate so if
you work through the unit analysis your
dimensional analysis on this this number
will come out samples divided by samples
per second gives you a number in seconds
a frame is a slice of the array
containing a fixed number of samples so
in the previous example we had 2 000
samples per frame
uh give or take
sorry it just started raining very hard
here in New York with uh some thunder
and lightning so hopefully that's not
coming too much through the microphone
but for example in this picture each of
these purple boxes corresponds to a
frame
and usually the length of the frame is
the same as nffft but not always not
everything is Fourier based but that's
if you're thinking that you're most of
the way there
The Hop length this is the number of
samples between adjacent frames
sometimes this will be called stride
sometimes it'll be called frame Advance
sometimes it might be parameterized
differently in terms of overlap between
frames but it's all the same idea it's
how much you move from one frame to the
next
and just a quick note in liberoso we
always Center our analysis windows and
there are technical reasons for this
that I won't get into but the idea is
that the nth frame is going to be
centered around the sample indexed at n
times The Hop length
okay
quick second example basically the same
code as before but what happens if we
don't want mono what if we want to do
stereo analysis or if we want to analyze
a batch of audio signals something like
that
we can do that we just say mono equals
false
and now we have a new array that has the
same length in terms of samples but now
we have two channels
and pretty much everything else in the
package will just work in the way that
you might expect if you're familiar with
things like torch or tensorflow where we
just have these multi-dimensional arrays
that just sort of fan out in the way
that we expect
so nothing really to worry about with
this
the conventions for data layout here the
trailing access the last thing you see
is always something like time whether
it's samples or frames
the leading axis is going to be channels
if it exists so if we have a stereo
signal y of zero will be the first the
Left Channel usually y of one will be
the right Channel and if you have more
than that you can just keep going
and you can use the dot dot dot notation
in numpy to just slice out
all the dimensions up to that
and anything in between the first and
last channels is going to correspond to
like a feature Dimension so it could be
a frequency it could be something else
so if you do a multi-channel short time
Fourier transform the first handle will
index which of the signals we're talking
about left or right
second dimension will correspond to the
frequency and then the last Dimension
will correspond to the time
and if you've done a bit of this kind of
thing with images or videos or something
like that that should be fairly familiar
okay so that was sort of the basic stuff
um we have a bunch of other things that
I'm not going to have time to get into
too much detail with here but the main
thing that you'll probably run into is
the feature module and we provide a lot
of feature extraction methods
four different kind of applications the
main one that you're likely to see is a
male spectrogram and this is essentially
taking the frequency axis and then
interpolating it on a logarithmic scale
so that every octave displacement is
equally spaced from the previous one
this is a very good thing if you're
using something like a 2d convolution
you want your convolutional filters to
cover the same effective frequency range
if you don't do a log scaling then the
ones at the bottom are going to cover a
much bigger range effectively than they
would at the top of the image
so for that reason and many others male
spectrums are very popular uh the rest
of these I don't really recommend unless
you know what you're doing
if you're doing music types of things
you might want to look at chroma
features which collapse things down to a
pitch class grid so rather than having
frequencies we have notes so we only
have 12 Dimensions here corresponding to
the chromatic scale C C sharp D D sharp
E Dot
and these can be useful for things like
chord recognition or maybe audio
fingerprinting things like that
we have some features for analyzing
Tempo and Rhythm and that sort of thing
that follow a similar sort of trajectory
I expect those probably won't come up
too much but Mel spectrograms definitely
are a good starting place for most
applications so I recommend you look at
those
we have some functionality for sequence
modeling
um so things like path alignment if you
have two versions of a signal maybe one
is faster than the other and you want to
figure out what time spots correspond to
each other uh we have functionality for
that we have functionality for looking
at recurrence analysis uh segmenting
songs that kind of thing
uh and one that you might want to look
at in a little bit more detail for your
applications if you're doing something
like time varying classification maybe
event detection or speech transcription
or something like that we have a bunch
of helper utilities for veteri decoding
which are really handy to have around
just to make it easy to sort of
post-process and smooth classifier
outputs so they don't flap from one
frame to the next this is a very useful
utility to have around
okay so I'm going to leave you with some
tips and tricks just to effectively use
this stuff in your own practice
first one if you're doing
um machine learning with audio
oftentimes you want to construct mini
batches for doing statistic gradient
descent and when you're making many
batches you want your signals to be all
the same length and that's often not the
case with audio so you need to extract
fixed dimensional patches
so you can do this by hand and it's
totally doable but it's kind of a pain
it's easy to mess up and it's easy to
blow up your memory if you do it wrong
but it turns out that if you're a little
bit clever with it you can actually use
the underlying frame slicer that we have
for spectrogram Generation to just slice
any sort of object
so here I'm using the frame utility
function to make patches that are always
32 frames long and advancing by 16
frames out of an arbitrarily shaped
spectrogram
and now if we had 128 frequencies by 230
frames
we do this past generation we have now
128 frequencies 32 frames per patch and
now we have 13 patches
and now you can sample from this to make
your mini batches and this all operates
without making any copies of the data
it's all in place very convenient
especially if you're doing training on
very large data sets this is a good
trick to have around
more high level this goes back to
something that Paige mentioned in the
previous talk uh there's no substitute
for having good data and for
understanding what your data is
and that's what liberosa can be very
helpful for is just getting a feel for
what these numbers actually mean but you
do need to understand a little bit about
what it's doing to your data
so by default librosa will resample any
audio signal to a standard 22khz
sampling rate and I get a lot of flack
for this but I still think it was a good
choice because it makes the API design a
lot simpler we have a blog post
explaining why we did this and how it
works and what you can do if you don't
want this particular default
but knowing that that's happening can
save you some headaches down the road
uh given that actually understanding
what the dimensions of your data mean
and correspond to in terms of like time
or samples or frames or any of that sort
of stuff that can help you in designing
your model architecture let's say you
want to build a comp net and you know
that the event that you're trying to
capture only really lasts for at most
half a second is never bigger than that
you can sort of use this sort of
thinking to think okay how big of a
filter do I actually need in my first
few layers to actually cover the event
that I'm trying to model knowing this
and having an intuition for what your
data layout is can be very helpful in
architecture design so I encourage you
to think about these things
some common pitfalls that I see people
do I'm not going to touch on all of
these
um
let's see which ones do I want to cover
the most uh I'll take the bottom two
first one trying to do everything end to
end uh from raw audio samples and
bypassing any sort of analysis or
spectrograms or anything like that that
can totally work it is fine to do that
however it usually requires a lot more
data to get the same performance at the
end
and
um what you end up with is not usually
that much better than just using a
spectrogram representation that you
already understand to start with
sometimes it can be better in some
situations and certainly that is the
direction that the research Community is
going but if you're data constrained or
resource constrained
try to think about using some clever
features that make your model a little
bit easier to fit it will save you some
time
parallel with that relying too much on
the default parameters as I mentioned at
the beginning our defaults are sort of a
baseline that's kind of tuned on average
to work for most applications but they
might not be the best for your problem
so it is good to spend some time
understanding what the parameters of the
analyzes actually do and whether or not
they fit what you're trying to do with
your model
and this just requires some domain
knowledge and a little bit of experience
but is worth the time to to learn these
things
so I'm going to stop here I'm going to
leave a couple links on the screen the
first one is the liberoso main website
that I'll point you did documentation
discussion forum Etc second one is our
GitHub repo if you have problems or bugs
or whatever if you want to make
contributions go there and the third one
is a link to a free textbook that I
wrote for my signal processing course
which just gives you a little bit more
background on what fundamentally all of
these operations are doing something
like a Fourier transform or sampling or
etc etc that's all covered in gory
detail in that book so I will stop here
and we can have questions and hang out
and chat so thank you
Maria you are muted oops
I knew we would have some audio uh issue
at some point because it's an event
about audio so there I was muted
um yes what I was going to say that I'm
going to leave this slide for a little
bit longer as I bring folks back
um
right
um so
let's see if we have any questions and I
think I'm going to start with the first
one that I that's rather easy which I
hope it is but um how did you come up
with the name for librosa it doesn't
really sound like audio well at least to
me so there must be a story behind it so
the story here was I just finished my
PhD and I was starting a postdoc in a
lab called labrosa
and that stood for the laboratory for
recognition and organization of speech
and audio
this was Dan Ellis's group at Columbia
University
over 10 years ago now uh hard to believe
it's been that long
and the idea part of the idea originally
was to sort of consolidate a bunch of
scraps of code that been kicked around
the lab and sort of handed off from one
grad student to the next and tweaked a
little bit every time just to sort of
bring that all in and make it internally
consistent and make it sort of the
package that the lab uses
so if we had labrosa the library for the
lab should be librosa following in the
grand Unix tradition of naming things
lib whatever
now that lab no longer exists Dan is off
at Google uh still doing Audio Research
and lots of great stuff
um
but
the package is still around so hey
software can live for a while
yeah it's a nice day story too um we've
had some questions in the chat also a
lot of librosa fans
thank you
um let me just quickly bring up the chat
and see
um so here's a question um do you have
any tips on making feature extractions
work on videos with audio using librosa
yes
um
so
okay so gory details the way that
librosa loads audio
it sort of multiplexes over two
different packages and those in turn
Multiplex over a bunch of different
libraries to do the different decodings
the default one that we use is lib sound
file snd file which does not do video
but it is faster more stable more
reliable Etc
as a fallback if you have a format that
sound file can't have handle we'll use a
package called audio read
and one of the things that audio read
can do is kick out to ffmpeg
so if you have say
um
I don't know a video you downloaded from
YouTube I don't know why you would never
download a video from YouTube Nobody
Does that but let's say you did that and
you wanted to extract the audio you
could just say librosa.load video file
and it will just pull out the audio
stream using audio read
so you don't have to work too hard to
make that work uh but it won't be as
fast as if you first extract the audio
signal using a tool like socks or or
something like that or even ffmpeg on
the command line and then use sound file
to just parse the converted audio stream
that's a slightly more stable way to do
it but otherwise there's no problem
um
with working with video files
there is um
a very specific question
um you have the rainbow gram phase and
Magnum one's spectrum is there any plan
to add an inversion for the rainbow
ground
uh there is a yeah so in the one of the
things in the documentation side is a
section called Advanced examples
so every function in liberosa has
example code where you can just copy
paste and get something that works but
the advanced example is a gallery of
more kind of
uh intricate examples that do a lot of
different things showing off different
pieces of the library together and one
of those is rainbowgram implementation
rainbow grams if you're not familiar
they're a visualization that try to show
both the magnitude and the phase
structure of the signal usually when we
see a spectrogram you're only seeing the
magnitude the color in a rainbow gram
corresponds to phase offset
so they can be they take a little bit of
training to learn how to read they're a
little bit difficult to work with and
they can be um
their subtleties to making them work
with different kinds of uh time
frequency representations whether it's a
short time foray transform or a constant
Q transform variable Q transform or
whatever it is
the example notebook that we give you
should be adaptable to those different
situations but there are so many
different ways that you might adapt them
that we haven't really figured out a
clean API to just make that a
visualization mode in itself but if you
want to undertake that we would be glad
to have it so please open an issue and
we can talk about it
there's a there's a question about
analysis and I thought of just Bridge a
second question on top of that so um you
mentioned that with the rhemogram it's
it can be difficult to learn how to
interpret these is also a case that
through familiarity with spectrograms
you also have an idea of like you can
look at a spectrogram and you can kind
of understand what's going on under the
hood
um and there's a question of do we
always do analysis in mono channel to
get to the point of using a spectrum
sure
um so I'll take the second question
first uh the answer do we always use
mono no but oftentimes we do usually
because there's a lot of redundancy
between a left and a right channel in
sort of an arbitrary audio signal that
you might want to analyze
however there are situations where
having multi-channel audio contains a
lot of information that you care about
most of those have to do with
localization so if I want to know that
I'm hearing an event like uh let's say a
police car driving by outside my window
from that direction
you kind of need two channels to
distinguish like this is more on the
right side than on the left side
and those are situations where you would
want to preserve the separate channels
all the way through your analysis
but if you just want to say is this a
police car yes or no you usually don't
need stereo for that
um but you know we support multi-channel
all the way through the stack
uh and then the first question
quick reminder
about about reading interpreting oh yeah
yeah this was
I I remember when I learned to do this
in grad school it was so much fun I just
stayed up all night with a couple
friends of mine just like loading up our
favorite songs
um and looking at spectrogram
visualizations and trying to understand
what was going on if you've never done
that with afex twin I highly recommend
it it's uh if you get the analysis
parameters right super cool equation
track definitely worth it but certainly
you can learn to identify
a lot of things in a spectrogram just
from looking at a picture
human voice is usually pretty easy to
pick out certain kinds of
instrumentation
um
I've known people that can do the same
thing by looking at mfcc plots which is
totally mind-blowing to me that is not a
skill that I ever hope to develop but
it's possible sure
and this is why like training cob Nets
on spectrograms works and makes sense
right because it's all just patterns of
spectropemporal energy
and and as a follow-up to that when if
you were to take a model and train it on
just raw audio do you think it learns
basically the same features that we that
the like a convolutional base model
would get from spectrograms are we like
implicitly going to spectrogram to final
representation or more or less yeah
um most of the time most of the examples
I've seen where you do this end-to-end
learning from the time domain
usually if you look at the first layer
filters uh and you organize them the
right way and and clean them up so
they're not just totally garbled and
noisy they tend to be things like um
either just sinusoids or approximately
sinusoids or you know spikes to catch
your impulses or things like Gabor
wavelets or
gamma tones or other things that are
sort of well understood in the signal
processing literature it tends to be the
same kind of thing except you learn a
subset of those that actually capture
the data that you trained on and not all
possible signals everywhere which is
what a Fourier transform would do
so you might get a little bit more
efficiency but
usually not more representation power
I just wanted to jump in to read one of
the comments that we got in the in the
chat and that is thank you sir after
five years of audio work today I got
answer why we use mono Channel thank you
so
um awesome
um do we have any more questions do you
see any more questions that um
we should
I think there was some general questions
kind of about what the best way of
learning about librosa is about docs if
someone is
useless before but wants to wants to
practice a bit more what what would you
where would you advise
um yeah I would start with the the
documentation site it's
pretty thorough I think
um you know I'm probably not the best
person to ask that of because
I maintained the thing but there are
lots of examples and I think
probably the easiest thing to do is pick
a simple task
um not like instrument classification
but like I don't know Tempo estimation
or pitch tracking or something maybe if
you're tracking is a little bit too much
but pick something simple
get like a
start from the example code that's in
the Galleries and the documentation
strings get something that works and
then start to pick apart what each of
those functions does and what happens if
you tweak the parameters a little bit
and that is a pretty good way to get a
feel for uh
how this stuff all hangs together and
what it does
maybe the book that you mentioned can
also be helpful in in exploring and
learning and I should say that we have
added it to supplemental resources to
the first unit of the course so if
you're going to be going through the
course you're going to see the book in
the supplemental resources as well
um I think at this point it is time to
start wrapping things up I'm gonna thank
you so much for the presentation it was
really interesting yes thank you for uh
maintaining the package and writing
awesome documentations uh documentation
on top of it and books and just
explaining things to us
um I'm I have one slide to finish things
today so these are all the important
links that are relevant to the course
and
um the course is already live the first
couple of units we have published today
and that's the first thing on the slide
the second link is the uh link to sign
up for the course updates and news and
events and things like that so you don't
miss a thing because we're going to be
releasing the course uh as I mentioned
before uh weekly so unions are going to
be published every week and of course
everybody should join our Discord where
we will be helping with questions and
where you can discuss your ideas and
brainstorm and um
learn from each other
as well as
um helping each other getting inspired
getting into discussions I'm gonna drop
these links also into the chat just a
second
um
there we go the links are there
once again thank you so much for uh
joining us uh thank you to our speakers
who have presented their uh very
captivating and Illuminating talks which
I'm sure going to be useful for
everybody who joins this course thank
you for everybody who stayed all the way
and asked questions and engaged with us
and I'm looking forward to seeing you on
Discord channels and interacting with
you answering your questions and have
fun
let's build something awesome
take care
thanks so much for joining
foreign